Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg are dead
serious about a cage match UFC president
Dana White says I think he's confused on
what a gimmick fight is is it going to
be one of the most watched fights of all
time yes does that make it not a gimmick
no this is the definition of a gimmick
fight you have two guys that have no
business fighting I just think Dana
White's bored I think he's over the
regular UFC matchups I think that's why
you have the power slap Fight League I
think that's why he's even entertaining
Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk in the UFC
he's just bored he just wants to mix it
up and this is another project for him
to do Dana wants to be involved in one
of the biggest fights of all time he
wants to be in the middle of it which he
would be to call this not a gimmick is
absolutely stupid insane this come from
a guy Dana that did a press conference
waits like I would never make Francis
and God of Tyson Fury these gimmick
fights we don't do that here then a week
later he's like Jon Jones Tyson fear I'm
down for that Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk
I'm down for that I just think he's
bored